let's go through the terms, 1 by 1, to
figure out what type each of them is. So
first we have y, y is not just a number,
so that means it cant be a constant term.
And we also know, that y is a frequently
used letter, to represent variables in
Algebra. So, y is a variable term. Then we
have 3 million. There are no symbols,
other than numbers in this term. And
we know that 3 million is a number, we
know how big it is already, so this has a
constant value, that means that its a
constant term. And lastly we have negative
-100,000x. Note that the negative sign
belongs with the term itself, so we dont
say that the term is 100,000x, we say that
it is -100,000x, anyway, this term has two
parts, it has a part with a number and a
part with a variable. As we talked about
before though if a term has a variable in
it at all, then that term counts as a
variable term. When we plug in numbers for
x -100,000x is going to change values
because of what we plug in. So the whole
term despite have a number in it counts as
a variable term.